hello everyone and welcome to another
really exciting game from the 2022 tata
still masters it's magnus carlson versus
avid gujarati and it's a game that you
guys requested as soon as it finished it
features a really really complicated
endgame but
uh it's really brief but also really
complicated so you guys will enjoy this
one let's dive straight into it and see
what uh
what happened and also what does this
mean for the standings so magnus with
the white pieces opens with e4 we have
e5 by viridit and now bishop the c4
magnus goes for the bishop's opening uh
sort of an attempt to
uh try and get it maybe out of his
comfort zone maybe he didn't check
whether this can lead to but of course
everyone checks everything nowadays and
it shouldn't be a problem so knight to
f6 we have d3 by magnus knight the c6
and the knight to f3 and we just
transpose into a normal two knights
defense uh with the
with uh white having played the d3 so
here bishop to c5 we transposing to the
joko pianissimo uh and knight to c3 now
we have h6 h3 and a6 a4 so you always
pretty much always see these four moves
played when there's uh
joko on the board uh we have d6 and now
uh
the position is a known one there is a
knight to e2 move in the database
between uh pavolanov and the linear
dominguez that was played in 2019 that
ended in a draw but here we have bishop
to e3 by magnus and it is now already as
of move 8 that we have a completely new
game so with it captures here we have
bishop capture spawn captures and now
bishop to e6 so magnus has now a doubled
e pawn but he also has an open f file
semi-open a file to be used for his rook
and now b3 by magnus here magnus also
offers visits to double his c pawn which
could be interesting because you already
have a double e pawn why not double
white c pawn as well so if b captures on
c4 now you have this you have this uh
but this is uh well actually good for
white even though double pawns aren't
all that great here you have immense
control over the b5 square so black
never has a b5 and you have all the
control in the world you want over the
d5 square so d5 might be an excellent
outpost for your knight plus later on
you can just play d4 and if anything
just get rid of your doubled pawns or or
you know many many possibilities here so
instead after b3 uh we just have castles
by vidit we have castles by magnus and
now as white allows it we always strike
in the center with d5 so e captures on
d5 knight captures on d5 now queen d2
developing connecting rooks and
defending the knight on c3 with its
traits we have captures captures and now
queen to d6 developing the queen also
connecting rooks and black can be very
very happy with his position here so
knight d2 shifting the knight over to d4
square will gain a nice tempo on the
queen and so f5 would prevent white from
doing so bishop captures an a6 queen
captures and now queen to c4 magnus
offers a queen trade and if video
accepts then magnus will get his
semi-open b file
so if it trades here with uh queen
captures b captures and now uh how do
you play this well there are a couple of
very nice ideas here you could start
with something like knights to be four
go after the the c2 pawn and then maybe
try and force magnus into a passive
position by defending the pawn via the
rook the c1 move but there's also
another really really cool line that
vidiq chooses and that is e4 so now he's
uh saying that all right we're just
gonna trade everything here and there's
not all that much you can do here so uh
of course we're going to play d4 this is
what magnus played and now another
beautiful move by with it f4 uh so this
puts pressure on the base of white spawn
chain that is the e3 pawn and if you
just capture on e4 we're just going to
capture an e3 and with it already has a
very nice past pawn on e3 the other rook
is coming to e8 which tempo uh the pawn
will be nicely protected and this will
be good for vidit so of course magnus
has to trade here we have rook captures
on f4 rook captures on f4 e captures on
f4 now uh removing the defender of the
d4 pawn and knight captures on d4 while
attacking the c2 pawn so magnus captures
an e4 knight captures on c2
rather not yet that's a doubled pawn we
don't want that one we want this one so
knight to the e2 with check uh
priorities here uh king f2 and knight
captures an f4 and now we have this
position uh where the material is equal
but as you can see uh that it has two
pawn islands magnus has three pawn
islands plus also he has a double c pawn
so uh who is better here uh let's check
it out rook to b1 first we go after the
b7 pawn with it of course defense with
b6 and now magnus again tries to create
a weakness with c5 always makes sense
you should always look for moves like
this you have a double c pawn if you
have a chance to undouble it or trade it
for for
your opponent's healthy pawn you should
always do so so rook to f8 now
threatening some nasty discoveries if
the knight moves but just c captures on
v6 uh so first we're gonna recapture
here uh we have c captures on b6 and now
c4 gaining control over the b5 square
and now we're going to try and go after
these pawns because if you just go rook
captures on b6 uh then we play knight to
d5 check open up a discovery and your
rook is lost so you have to be very
careful so c4 here for the moment not a
lot of good discoveries here but it does
go for knight to d5 check king e2 and
now rook to e8 going after the knight
and now uh basically it is offering a
trade of knights to go into a full rook
end game so magnus accepts this it's the
best white can do because this also
gives the white the past pawn so rook
captures an e4 with check king to d3 and
this is the the position where the fun
really starts how do you play this
position uh of course you could capture
the pawn on a4 this gives you not one
but two pass pawns and of course the
white is threatening to pick up the b6
pawn so that's also an issue here uh how
do you continue playing this well vidiq
played rook captures on a4 as any sane
person would do
the problem is that's not how you play
this uh interestingly you played this by
uh playing rook f4 right it's a
disgusting engine defensive idea
that says that i played rook f4 and now
i'm just going to bring my king into the
game and i don't care what you do
obviously the king can't come any
further into the game so your only move
is basically rook captures on g6 but
this will not do if you play rook
captures then i'm capturing an a4 and
now this is fine this is probably what
david had in mind he probably thought
rook captures on a4 rook captures on b6
and that's it however after capturing on
a4 magnus doesn't automatically capture
on b6 rather magnus plays d6 that's the
difference first uh
magnus grabs more space here and now d78
are already a pretty big threat which
could have been avoided if you
transferred the move to white which is
never an easy thing to do when you're
playing an endgame and you can snatch a
pawn you you are snatching that pawn so
king to f7 with it has to bring the king
closer to the past pawn now comes the
rookie one magnus cuts off with its king
from advancing any further and now rook
to a5 hoping to get the rook to d5 check
in to pick up the pawn so king d4 not
allowing this and now rook back to a2
now we're gonna have to check the white
king from the from behind yeah in order
to prevent any any advancement so king
d5 rook to d2 with check we have king to
c6 and now with it plays b5 as the b6
pawn is attacked he now also wants to
start pushing his pass pawn but now the
position is winning for magnus uh
but it's again not an easy move to find
especially if you have a little time on
the clock which is interesting as magnus
did not have a little time on the clock
he had plenty of time on the clock so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this incredibly difficult
move to find while i give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to
solve this one congratulations you are a
true master of the end game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is rook the e7 check it's a move
you wouldn't expect because a good move
you know a good continuation or rather a
series of moves
rarely starts with a check but here it
does and it comes with a very specific
idea you want to give this check and
after the king moves to f6 or somewhere
you're going to play rook to e4 and this
is very very important
but
for you to for you to easily understand
it i'm just gonna show you why uh black
is gonna repeat king f7 uh and now we're
gonna play d7 that's the good stuff and
now after rook to c to check we're gonna
play king to b6 and after rook to d2
threatening to pick up the pawn we're
going to play king c7 rook to c to check
we're going to play king to d8 and now
after uh black starts pushing you can't
play b for the b4 square is covered by
the rook so we're going to play a5 now
we play rook to e7 check king to f8 and
now rook back to e5 you have to play
rook to e5 this is super important uh so
of course black doesn't want to allow f
rook to f5 check
black is going to play f5 but now we
play rook captures on b5 because you if
you allow this check then the king comes
into the game and then it's all over and
now for example a4 we're gonna play rook
k5 and after something like rook c4
defending the pawn just to rook a7 and
the rook the c7 is coming that's it this
is how we shield our king from any uh
checks the the black rook might give us
after g5 just rook c7 and that's it once
the rook moves doesn't really matter
where we're gonna play king c8 and
promote our pawn to a queen and win the
game however in the game after b5 was
played and magnus did not find rook to
e7 check magnus played d7 right away so
like a vidit a couple of moves
prior now magnus makes the the sub
optimal move and now it's completely
different because the continuation is
exactly the same however uh it the uh
you know that takes a takes a different
turn at some point so uh rook the seat
you check king b6 rook to d2 going after
the pawn everything the same like we
already discussed king to c7 rook to c
to check king to d8 and now as you
if you recall in that line that we've
shown the rook was an e4 so you don't
have this b for push but here magnus
allowed with it to push b4 and b4 can be
a deadly deadly move in any given
position
so now you're already close to b3 b2 and
b1 queen uh so here rook to e7 checked
by magnus king of f8 now magnus goes
rookie three he guards the b3 square not
all that much to do king of seven we
repeat rook d7 check king f8 uh rook to
e5 uh so what do you play uh g6 we you
do not want to allow this uh king rook
to f5 check we discussed this in the
previous line uh so g6 is played and
then now comes rook to e6 again if you
play rook to e4 you go after the pawn we
just push the pawn and if rook to f4
check yes you now have delivered check
but uh the rook has to be on the fifth
rank not not on the fourth rank because
after king to g7 we're gonna play king
e7 hoping to promote our pawn rookie two
check we're gonna play king to d6 and
now rook to d to check and that's why
it's important that the rook is on the
fifth rank so you can block with rook to
d5 check here the rook is on the fourth
rank that's why the g6 move was
incredibly important this is something
you uh have to
have to know when you're in a rook uh
rook end game so if you have a chance
you know grab any book or anything that
explains rocket games uh you know stuff
like this is definitely in there so king
to e7 rook to 82 check and now after
king to d6 we are just going to have a
repetition of moose because there's no
way for the white king to shield
himself from all the checks so instead
after g6 magnus played rook the e6 uh he
now tries to attack the pawns here but
now b3 that it's pawn is much too fast
rook to f6 check king to g7 now comes
king the e7 defending the rook now
getting this pawn to d8 but now comes
rook e to check we have broke the e6 yes
now you have
accomplished this but the b2 pawn is
already very very close so rook captures
with czech king captures and now b2 we
have d8 queen and b1 queen so now both
players have a queen in the game uh but
vidit is actually up upon his king is uh
maybe you know not in in the greatest
position possible but it doesn't matter
because there's no way to take advantage
of this so magnus plays queen to c7
check we have kinked the g8 and now
there is no good way to continue queen
f7 check we're just going to put the
king on h8 there's not all that much you
can do here queen guards the the g6 pawn
so nothing fun happening here so magnus
just played queen to d8 to check king to
g7 and it was in this position on move
51 that uh players agree to a draw as
there is nothing more to be done here
so really a a fine game uh that really
shows you how uh
unforgiving chess can be and how
unforgiving chess could be if uh if uh
played uh
with the absolute uh
uh precision uh for example this
position that we discussed just uh after
king attacks rook who who doesn't
capture the pawn you know who who
amongst us would not capture this a4
pawn uh you absolutely have to capture
this but that's not the way to go rook
to f4 is the idea and then we have this
uh again incredible position after
uh this pawn was pushed you have to go
for this rookie seven check followed by
rook back to uh
rook back to e4 and then we we we can
shield ourselves from all the
unnecessary checks but also we need to
prevent the the advancement of the b
pawn first so really uh a tricky tricky
situation and a detail that not uh
that you don't easily pick up and if
magnus didn't pick it up with uh
more than sufficient time on the clock
then you have a general idea of how how
difficult rook and games are
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we're gonna check out the
standings i don't know if i will be
covering any more games uh from this
round i will try but uh you know it's
not really all
the all the way up to me uh so these are
the standings magnus still leading the
tournament with a half a point again um
ahead of rihanna rapport who got his win
today uh as daniel dubois
did not show up he was tested positive
so he will not be joining the tournament
or rather he might there are some uh
ideas that he might if he like tests
negative the next day uh there are some
discussions about that uh but we'll see
so rapper in second place with seven and
a half anisha lost his game today uh so
he remains on six and a half if he won
against jordan he would have joined
magnuson seven and a half then uh we
have mamidarov on six and a half with
six we have uh penko karjakin vedic and
caruana on five and a half year in fun
forest after his win against anish today
duda on five
uh we have sam shanklin on four and a
half daniel dubo uh on three and a half
uh also on three and a half niels
grandelius and pragananda so those were
the standings hope you guys enjoyed that
as well and yeah really fun game uh
chess is is just uh you know always uh
uh keeps uh impressing us and you know
just dazzling us with all this beauty
and uh the end game is just so rich and
full of possibilities that
even if you are the world champion uh it
doesn't mean that you can just win a
winning end game
uh so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed that uh i would like to thank
adam chaplin uh mateo shujak mike
mccafferty uh deepak bhatt and
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this spectacular event uh
until it finishes uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day